[Applause]
there's a way to avoid this problem a
way to avoid having a proof that says
hey this is cool but right we can prove
this without the the but you know the
however we can actually just use the
classic form of this proof which will
limit us to
just integer values of m
the classic proof which i'm about to
present to you for demoira's theorem
think about this
what knowledge do we have what kind of
area of mathematics that allows us to
prove things
where only integer values are relevant
maybe your brain is ticking over because
we read it we met it not that uh long
ago we're going to use the principle of
mathematical induction now i always used
to think of it as kind of like this
shortcoming of mathematical induction
that it was only true for integer values
i was like ah well that's kind of a bit
of a pain isn't it but actually it's
sort of elegant it's kind of like using
the right tool for the job um you know
if we want to prove that something is
true only for integer values let's prove
it true using a tool that is suitable to
integer values so that's what we're
going to do here
now i do want to remind you that
mathematical induction because the whole
idea is you kind of are knocking over a
set of dominoes it has to start
somewhere and then it goes in integer
steps up to
infinity right so we have to choose a
starting point which kind of has its own
challenge because i want all integer
values including negative ones so
there's not any neat starting point that
i can go from the you know a beginning
and then go in one direction because
you'll always miss the other half of the
integers right so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to sort of start at a
pretty standard place which is zero um
you know often proofs by induction will
start at one or zero most of them will
start there i mean sometimes they start
at weird spots but this is fairly common
i'm going to go from zero
through the counting numbers one two
three four and so on and then what we're
going to do is make a slight
modification a bit of an addition at the
end rather than a subtraction um to sort
of capture our negative cases as well
okay so we're going to prove demolition
theorem is true by mathematical
induction you may recall that uh proof
of mathematical instruction essentially
have three steps we're going to test
what we call the base case which in this
case is n equals 0 the first time that
we're considering for this um statement
over here to be true we're going to test
where they're going to assume that it's
true for some general case usually n
equals k and then we're going to use
that assumption to prove that it's true
prove that's the third step for the next
step k plus 1
if it's true for the previous step n
equals k so let's have a go
step one
is test so i'm going to do this in some
colors just so we can follow it more
easily so we're going to test for n
equals 0. here we go what is the left
hand side
and the left hand side will just be
equal to cos theta
plus i sine theta because remember we
unlike before when we were just trying
to show there was a problem
and we tested a particular value of
theta i need to prove that demand
theorem works for all values of theta so
that's why i'm leaving it there general
i raised that to power of 0
but anything to the power of 0 is by
definition 1 so i can state that i then
have a look at the right hand side and
i'm going to get cos of
0 theta
plus i sine
of 0 theta it's just me doing straight
substitution that's weirdly cos of 0
plus i sine 0 which i've already done a
couple of times earlier today that's
going to be 1 plus 0 i which is 1 as
required that's the left hand side as
well
okay
so far so good i've tested for my first
case now this is the easy step i'm going
to assume that this statement is true
except rather than for some general n
i'm going to assume that it's true for
some specific
k so i'm going to assume that this is
true
where i've got k's instead of n's so i'm
going to put that k up there
okay here and k
there so this is assuming that it's true
for n equals k
and now i'm going to prove that it's
true for n equals k plus 1. so what's
that going to look like well it's going
to be cos theta plus i sine theta that's
raised to the value of k plus 1 equals
cos of okay here we go big brackets k
plus 1 lots of theta
and then sine with k plus 1
lots of theta okay that looks good to me
so from here i'm using this as my
foundation right this is the n equals k
case and now i need to prove like i
don't know that this is true i'm going
to try and prove the k plus 1 case so
start from the left-hand side stuff on
the right hand side in many ways it
doesn't really matter but i think it
might be easier to use the assumption if
i start from the left-hand side so here
comes the proof
i'm going to say the left-hand side
equals and i'm just going to take it as
written here it is
and i accidentally brought a couple of
extra brackets along for the right okay
there we go now i'm just going to start
doing some algebra on this right k plus
1 as the power means that this thing
gets multiplied by itself
until k you've done it k times and then
you have one more time that's the plus
one so therefore i'm going to write that
one more time as a separate thing right
so it'll be cos theta plus i sine theta
there's the the extra one and then the
rest of it is cos theta plus i sine
theta
to the power of k so you can see how if
i add these two indices you get the k
plus one up here right
what's great about this line is you can
see i can use this this
expression here i can do a substitution
using my um using my assumption over
here and that's kind of the point of
proof by induction so what i've got is
uh this cos theta plus i sine theta that
term is hanging out the front
and then
i put a big set of brackets here i'm
going to use this because apparently
that's equal to
cos theta plus i sine theta to the power
of k i'm going to duplicate that not
move it
down here
there is my substitution and i'm going
to say because i'm using the inductive
hypothesis here the n equals k case i'm
going to say by assumption
[Music]
okay so at this point um i've done my
substitution from from this line uh into
here and now i'm ready to just kind of
expand out and hopefully i can use some
trigonometric identities to get to this
all right so i'm just going to do the
expansion so first i get cos theta
that's going to distribute to both of
these terms so cos of k theta
plus
let's see what am i going to get here i
is going to be out the front and then
cos theta sine
of k theta that looks good now i'm going
to distribute the the i sine theta to
both of these terms inside the square
brackets so that gives me i
of sine theta cos
k theta and then for my final part of
the expansion
whoops it easy i
times i here is going to give me i
squared and then i've got two sine terms
pairing together so that's going to give
me plus i
squared sine theta sine of k theta
okay now this is great what i'm going to
do is uh notice that i've got some real
and imaginary terms here yes so
this part here this is going to be real
it's got no eyes on it
this part has eyes on it at the moment
but the i squared is going to cancel to
give me negative 1. and that leaves
these terms in here where the i doesn't
cancel so i might as well factor it out
and that gives me the imaginary term so
on left hand side here let's use orange
just to keep it consistent i'm going to
have cos theta
cos of k theta
and then the minus comes from the i
squared along the end there i get sine
theta
sine of k theta
and then i'm going to
i'm going to take out i'm going to
factorize out the common factor of i and
that leaves me with
i'm going to switch out the order here
just because of the normal way that i
write this i'm going to get the sine
theta cos
k theta term there and then i'm going to
get cos theta it's just flipped around
there the sine k theta
another in fact i'm going to write those
as big brackets just so i don't confuse
them
and there we go so what have i got here
well if you have a look carefully at
this remember when we're always proving
things we keep one eye on our current
working and another eye on this right
hand side that's where i'm trying to go
right i started with the left which is
here and i'm going to here
i've got a trigonometric identity kind
of screaming out at me right this this
here is a compound angle identity except
that the compound angle that i've got is
not like a plus b it's going to be cos
of
theta plus k theta so i'm going to write
that theta plus
k theta
and then i've got this i
and i've got another compound angle
identity over here except it's not for
cos it's a sine how convenient so i've
got sine of again theta plus k theta and
now finally all i need to do here is to
factorize out the fetus inside those
angles there which gives me in the first
instance
the k plus 1
factoring out the theta
and then the
k plus 1 again
outside of that theta
and that is my right hand side as
required so
well done you just proved um four n
equals zero one two three and so on we
just proved that demarva's theorem is
true
for this set of um this part of the set
of integers so i should say i should
conclude therefore
i'm going to just take this statement
this
is true
[Music]
over here
and how did i do it it was
by the principle
of mathematical induction you should
always conclude your proofs
[Music]
okay now
like i sort of alluded to before we have
kind of only done half the job
mathematical induction starts at a point
it's like oh look at this domino and
then it pushes all the dominoes over
after that using this mathematical logic
this mathematical argument but because
we have to start somewhere in the case
here we started with 0 and then go
onwards we've left out
n equals negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 and so on going to negative infinity
so i have to deal with that somehow so
the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to say well
let's just go back to this right because
i'm considering
you know all of these complex numbers on
the unit circle i want to consider what
happens when i deal with negative
indices so if i have this z equals cos
theta
plus i sine theta which is a complex
number on the unit circle what happens
when i raise this to the power of
negative one uh that was sort of the the
quintessential negative index and then i
can deal with all of the rest of the
negative indices on the basis of what i
learned from this
well
a negative index is just division right
it's the reciprocal of cos theta plus i
sine theta so what i can write is this
is equal to 1 over
cos theta
whoopsie daisy
i think i grabbed it there it is cos
theta plus i sine theta and as soon as
you see this you should think oh i want
to deal with the fact that the
denominator is complex what i can do is
i can just multiply through by the
conjugate of the denominator and that
will
realize my denominator so what i'm going
to multiply by is not cos theta plus i
sine theta it's going to be cos theta
minus i sine theta so i'm going to grab
that
and multiplying by that over that
there's no change to the actual fraction
okay so this is good i can say 1 times
that conjugate is just going to give me
that conjugate on the top i don't need
to go that far over what do i get on the
denominator well the reason why we
multiply by the conjugate is because we
can use difference of squares here right
this pair of denominators is in the form
a plus b
times a minus b so difference of squares
of course factorizes to give you a
squared minus b squared in that case in
this case it's cos squared theta
take away
i squared
sine squared theta you can kind of see
where this is going right
this is going to be equal to
i've still got my cos theta minus i sine
theta
on the numerator the conjugate but then
what have i got on the denominator well
that minus and that i squared are going
to cancel with each other giving me plus
sine squared theta and this is
delightful because i have the
pythagorean identity on the denominator
which means i can just write the
denominator as 1.
let's be super lazy and grab that
because i wrote it neatly enough i think
that's equal to 1.
so therefore i can say that's equal to
interestingly when i take the
reciprocal of a complex number if it's
on the unit circle the complex number
that you get
is exactly the conjugate and you can
think about that geometrically as well
okay now what can i do with this well i
can actually use the fact that i can
raise this to um a power a positive
integer power using this proof by
induction that i just did right i've
just built a foundation to say hey this
demo moivre's theorem thing it works for
n equals zero one two etc um you know
zero and all the positive values so
let's raise everything you can see on on
on this left and right hand side to this
power what am i gonna get well it's
going to give me z to the power of
negative 1 to the power of n
on the left hand side but that gives me
cos
n theta minus
i
sine of n theta that's going to give me
that on the right hand side right so you
can see i've used demarva's theorem so
long as i'm still restricting myself to
this part because that's that's all i've
proven is true right
and the positive integers but now i can
say wait i can i can work with this line
a little bit right for starters on the
left hand side i've got index laws so i
just get negative n over there
and then on the right hand side i can
use the symmetry of the trigonometric
functions this is this delightful result
being using over and over again right
cos is an even function so therefore
cos of n theta is the same as cos of
negative n theta yes and here this minus
i sine n theta sine is an odd function
so therefore i can write this as plus i
sine
negative n theta because of the oddness
the odd symmetry you get in that
function
now what have we got here this
is de moivre's theorem but lo and behold
i'm taking it for negative values of
these arguments considering that n up
here has to be positive so negative n
must be a negative number and it's the
same in here so therefore what i've
shown is that theorem holds true not
just for um you know n equals zero one
two one following but also for the
negative numbers because i can
substitute anything you know into n here
that i like even if i get a negative it
still all works using these properties
so in summary um dwyer's theorem is
marvelous but you have to be careful
with it and even though this
this proof using mathematical induction
seems so much longer than what we did
before with the exponential form of a
complex number and what's great in it is
that you don't have to say but you know
you don't just say this proof is true
but be cautious with it this proof is
true and it's true for exactly what it
says it is for
n equals 0 and up to the positive
integer values and also for the negative
values that you get down here